[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT KUBIS: First of all, I
want to start off a little bit,
what am I going to
talk about today.
Because if you see
this, and you think,
this is not what
you expected, please
feel free to change rooms.
I don't want to
keep anybody here
that doesn't get
what they expect.
So first of all, I'm going
to start with Cloud Spanner
architecture recap.
So I want to get everybody
on the same page, what's
the terminology, how does Cloud
Spanner work under the hood?
OK?
Second is the schema and
[INAUDIBLE] optimization.
So I'm going to talk about
common challenges, or things
that we see when developers
and operators work
with Cloud Spanner.
So I'm going to address those.
I'm going to talk about
multi-region configurations.
What are they good for, and what
does it mean behind the scenes?
And then, at the end, I also
give some recommendations
about related
sessions to this one.
So first of all, a
little bit about myself.
I am a developer advocate for
the Google Cloud Platform.
I'm concentrating on
storage and database system,
with a very deep passion
on Cloud Spanner.
So I've worked with Cloud
Spanner a for over a year now.
I've done the keynote
demo last year,
where we demonstrated
the scale of Spanner.
And today, and in
this Next '18, we're
basically looking at
manageability of Cloud Spanner.
What is a Cloud
Developer Advocate?
We understand ourselves to be
the bidirectional interface
between developers, operators
that build on our platform,
and the developers and
the operators that build
the platform inside Google.
So please, please, please
feel free to reach out to me.
You find me on Twitter.
You find me on other channels.
If you have challenges, if
you have recommendations
how to do things better, we have
always an open ear for that.
All right.
First of all, I want
to check a little bit,
do a pulse check of
who is here today.
Who is a developer
here in the room?
All right.
That is awesome.
That's my audience.
Who is an operator?
OK.
ITDM, CXO?
We have a couple.
Welcome.
That's very good.
Who is using already
Cloud Spanner today?
Oh, awesome.
Awesome.
OK.
So half the room is using it.
So for you, it's basically a
refresher at the beginning.
And then, I hope I can show
you a couple of tricks,
how to get the most
out of Cloud Spanner.
All right.
So if you read the statement
about Cloud Spanner,
we are a relational
database server
that provides strongly
consistent actions,
and that scales horizontally.
Now, that sounds
pretty awesome, right?
So if you look at
these things separate,
you have that around today
in many, many phases.
If you look at strongly
consistent databases,
there are relational
databases out there
for 40 years-plus, very
hardened and everything.
But they don't have
the scalability aspect.
Now, if you take
the transactional,
the consistency away,
you have for 10-plus--
15-plus years, the so-called
[INAUDIBLE] scale databases
around that give you the
horizontal scalability,
but you do have to sacrifice
on the consistency.
Now, Cloud Spanner tries
to combine these things,
and I'm going to talk about
how we are doing this.
So let's start with
an architecture recap.
First of all, about
the terminology--
there are a couple
of things that
are very familiar to people that
work with relational databases.
So we have an instance, which
basically gives your resource
pool, your nodes that you
have and how much data
you can store in an instance.
Then you can store, I
think, up to 100 databases
in an instance.
And in each database, you can
store up to 2,048, I believe,
tables.
Now, these are the
constructs that
are visible to everybody
outside, if you use Spanner.
And those are the
concepts that you're
used to if you work with
relational database.
Now, to provide the
scalability in Cloud Spanner,
we have another construct
which is hidden from you.
And that is called a split.
So basically, what
we are doing--
all the tables are
ordered lexicographically
by the primary key.
And then, we divide them into
chunks that we call split.
And that allows us to scale.
We can basically hand these
chunks between the resource
nodes that we have
available, and make
them responsible for
different splits.
And by that, we get the
scalability that we see.
So if you look at an
architectural view
of a regional instance,
you have three zones
for a regional instance, and
you have your compute resources
and your storage resources.
Now, they are
independent scalable.
We have some
restrictions, how many
nodes you have to
have, at least,
for a certain amount of data.
So per two terabyte, you
need at least one node.
So you cannot scale further
down than this restriction.
But other than that, you can
scale to thousands of nodes,
even if you have only a
couple of terabytes of data.
Now, in your zones, you
have basically the compute.
For each node that you buy
from us in the Cloud console,
you get this node three times
replicated, once in each zone.
And then you have the
storage which, again, is also
replicated, which is
not illustrated here
in this graphic.
But storage is also replicated
to I don't know how many
nines of durability.
Now, one thing that we need
to basically organize and have
this strong,
consistent system is
something to
basically synchronize
who is responsible for a
certain part of your data.
And we never, never,
never want to have
two compute resources be
responsible for the same data.
Because that is where
inconsistencies come in.
So we needed some
kind of mechanism
to make sure that we never have
two owners of a data piece.
Now, one way to do this
is with communication.
But communication, especially
if you go further away from each
other-- so if these zones are
a couple of milliseconds apart
from each other--
you basically incur round trips.
So if you look at-- for
additional databases,
they ensure consistency with
the two-phase permit protocol.
And for the two-phase
commit protocol,
you need multiple
round trips basically
to ensure this consistency.
Now, that is very expensive and
it wouldn't scale, obviously.
So we needed another way
to ensure the consistency
while being able to remove
this additional communication.
And the way that we did this
is that we invented TrueTime
with the Spanner system.
So what is TrueTime here?
So now, if you look
at TrueTime, TrueTime
is basically a system
that quantifies
the worst possible error,
or drift, between clocks
all over the world.
So in all our data centers, we
have so-called GPS [INAUDIBLE]
and time [INAUDIBLE],,
atomic clocks, which
are synchronized through GPS.
And then, we can quantify
how much they drift, at most.
And by this, we are able to
basically choose this timestamp
interval, where we can say that
the lower end of this interval
has passed everywhere, and
the upper end of this interval
has passed nowhere.
So you see there, if I
read the TrueTime now
returns in interval
T1 and T2, where
T2 is T1, so the lower
bound plus 2 epsilon, which
is basically our
security, in terms
of the drift that we expect.
And then, T1 is
guaranteed to be lower
than the value of the
global clock at the instance
when now finishes executing.
So when you get this interval,
this has definitely passed.
And T2 is guaranteed
to be higher
than when this [INAUDIBLE]
now starts executing.
So we use this
interval-- this TrueTime
interval-- to ensure
strong consistency
across the database.
And not only within one region.
We can do that across
the regions, even.
So let's look at a little
bit about how does it work.
Let's start with a
simple life of a query.
So here, in this case, I
want to do a consistent read,
so I basically want to get the
latest state of my database.
And we choose here
a select statement,
so I select from Event,
where the name is Next 2018.
Now, the request comes
in from your client.
It goes through a
follower because that's
the one that is closest--
the follower of the split.
So you basically
have the Paxos group,
where you choose a leader, and
then you have two followers.
And then the leader
is basically who
holds the hold-throughs of
your data for that split.
Now, the request comes
into your follower,
and the follower sends a request
to the leader of this Paxos
group and says, hey, do
I have the latest data?
And if the leader
sends back and says,
yes, this timestamp
is what I have.
If you have this timestamp,
you have the latest data,
the follower serves
the data back.
So there's no data going between
the leader and follower here.
It's really just to check,
do I have the latest data?
Now, in the case that the data
is not there yet, basically
the leader responds saying, hey,
you don't have the latest data.
This is the timestamp
of the latest data.
Please wait that out till
you see the timestamp
And once you see it,
you can serve the data
because then you know that
you have the latest data.
Right.
We have, also, another
construct in Spanner,
which we use for optimization,
especially if you
use a global
instance and you want
to have fast response times.
You can do something which
is called time-bounded reads.
And time-bounded reads
are not consistent--
not strong consistent.
They are consistent.
They are consistent
time-bounded reads,
but they are not the
latest ones, basically.
Now, for a time-bounded
read, so-called stale read,
you can define the boundary.
You can say, OK, I accept
data, which is up to,
let's say, 15 seconds old.
Or you can actually
define an instance of time
within one hour.
So we allow up to
one hour that you
can go back in time with
a time-bounded read.
And in the time-bounded read,
in many, many, many, many, many,
many, many cases--
especially if you use a
15-second time bound--
the data is already
there for your follower.
Because if we have
a transaction, not
directory as part of the
transaction, but immediately,
when this transaction
is happening,
we are sending out that
data to all the followers.
So they have that
actually pretty quickly.
So here, in this case, if we do
a request and we say we allow
15-seconds-old data, the
follower basically checks,
do I have--
if the data hasn't
changed for a while,
we basically send a
heartbeat to update,
this is the latest data.
Then we can say,
OK, I have the data.
I don't need to
go to the leader.
I can directly serve that data,
and I leave the leader alone,
which is pretty amazing.
Now, I want to look into writes.
So I mentioned one thing
is two-phase commit
is something that is expensive.
Another thing which
is expensive is locks.
So Spanner was designed in a
way you only use what you need.
So if you don't
need certain things,
you don't pay the
penalty of, for instance,
a two-phase commit.
So as an example, if you go
into a traditional database
and you want to have--
you do a transaction, but
you only read something
in this transaction.
You don't actually
write something.
You still acquire
locks and you still
have certain two-phase commits
in some of the systems.
And you basically pay
the penalty for that,
even though you have maybe
not even changed any data.
Now, in Spanner, we allow for
certain kinds of transactions
to actually be
lockless, and we allow
for certain kinds
of transactions,
actually, for
locks to be shared.
So here's an example of
a single split write.
In a single-split write--
let's say it's a point
update, and let's also
say it's a blind update.
So I'm not reading anything.
I just say, this
value, with key 100,
I want to write A. As you
see, on the left side,
I want to write, for
key 100, the value A.
So what's happening,
basically, this comes in,
let's say, through
the API front end.
And we do a split
and leader lookup.
Now, this is very
heavily cached.
I left it in here in the graph.
But basically, the round-trip
that you see to the zone
master, is rarely, rarely
happening because we are
caching very heavily
in the front-end,
where the splits are living, and
where the leaders are for these
splits.
So we basically get back
who the split leader is.
So we're sending, to the split
leader, the commit request.
And I would actually
change the slide right now,
because there is an error.
This send commit request
goes to the split leader,
not to the other replicas.
I apologize for that mistake.
Now, what the split
leader does, it
basically acquires a
write lock, and then
assigns a TrueTime timestamp
waits out that time.
While waiting out this time,
we send a persist request
to the other replicas.
As soon as we get the
majority of acknowledge
that this change was
persisted, we basically say,
OK, quorum is reached.
We just wait out the
through time upper bound.
We know, at that
time, it's persistent,
and then we send back,
to the front-end,
or to the client, that the
transaction was successful.
Now, I mentioned this
is a blind write.
And in a blind write, we can
actually share the write locks.
So if you have multiple
blind write transactions,
they can share the write
lock, which is amazing.
So you can actually just use
TrueTime for the ordering,
and they are not
conflicting, and we
can share the write locks.
All right.
So let's make that a little
bit more complicated.
Now, in this case, we
have a multi-split write.
So here, what I'm doing
is I'm reading the value
from the key 100.
I'm writing a value to
key 100, the value A.
I'm writing, to the key 300,
the value B. And to the key 400,
the value C.
Now again, we do the split
leader lookup for our read
because that's the first
thing that we send.
Now, we send the read
request to the split leader
of the zone A, split zero.
That is where my key value
100 lives, and the leader is.
And the leader
acquires a read lock--
read locks, again,
can be shared--
and sends the result back.
Now, on my client,
I do something,
and then I'm sending the writes.
I'm sending the write for
100, for 300, and 400.
So before I send
that, of course,
I have to do the lookup, where
the leaders for these values
live.
Then I send the commit
requests to my split leader
of the zone A split zero, which
is my key 100 split leader.
Then I send it to zone C, split
two, which is my key 300 zone
and split leader.
And then to zone
B and split three,
which is my zone
leader for the key 400.
Now, what the front-end
is doing, as well,
is when we do this
writing section,
it is choosing a leader of
this multi-split transaction.
We need, basically,
a leader who is
in control of this transaction.
Now, since it is
multi-split, we actually
have to do two-phase commit.
In the single write, we didn't
But since this is
multi-split, we actually
have to coordinate between
the different Paxos groups,
so we have to do have
a two-phase commit.
So when we attempt
the commit request,
each of the split leaders
is requesting their locks.
So I basically do the write lock
for the zone B, a write lock
for the key 300, and I do
also verify the read lock
for the first one that I did.
I am also writing this key,
so I am also requesting
a write lock for that.
And then, once all these
locks are required,
I send, basically, that
back to the chosen leader
or coordinator of
this transaction.
So now, what is happening, once
I have all these confirmations
that my locks are acquired,
and they are still valid,
the leader basically
assigns a TrueTime
timestamp to that transaction,
records the commit
to some replicas.
And once it gets a majority
of this in their Paxos group,
it sends it out to the
other split leaders.
And then the other
split leaders is
recording that commit to the
replicas in their Paxos group.
And as soon as they have
the majority, they then--
they basically are
prepared for that commit.
And then, once this
is done, basically, we
know that the commit is done.
The first phase was
basically verifying
that we have all the locks, and
that we can get all the locks.
The second phase here,
you see, is basically,
yes, please commit
that transaction.
We have all the locks, so we
can commit this transaction.
We again made out the
TrueTime uncertainty,
and report back
the commit success
to all our other participants
of that transaction.
And then, in parallel pretty
much, the mutation is applied.
Now, if there's any
point in time where
we have a lock conflict-- for
instance, I acquire read lock,
and another transaction
has a read lock, as well.
And then I want to upgrade
that read lock to a write lock.
But since the other
transaction has a read lock,
I cannot upgrade it
to the write lock.
What is happening in Spanner
is, basically, we do a wait
and wound.
So basically, what
it is doing, it
is going to cancel-- abort,
basically-- the transaction
that is younger.
So the front-end knows the
ordering of the transaction.
And if they see there's
a looming deadlock,
we are basically aborting
the younger transaction,
let proceed the
older transaction.
And then we just retry
the younger transaction
that we aborted.
All right.
So with that knowledge,
what are the things
to look out for when
working with Cloud Spanner?
So first and foremost-- and
one of the most straightforward
ones sometimes still missed--
is the choosing of the
right primary keys.
So primary keys, I
mentioned in the beginning,
the tables are ordered
lexicographically.
Or for the mere mortals,
alphanumerically.
So if you have something
which is monotonic
increasing or
decreasing, you basically
add to the last split,
or to the first split.
And as mentioned,
one split is always
owned by one computer source.
So if you always
add to one split,
you basically exhaust the
computer sources on that split.
So the recommendation, use
well-distributed primary keys,
or composite primary
keys if you can.
Also, look at
reordering your table
if you see that that can
help in getting your key more
distributed-- your component
primary key more distributed.
Another thing is be
careful with interleaving.
So interleaving can be powerful.
Interleaving is a technique
where you basically
make sure that the data lives
on the same split as the parent
table.
So you interleave it
in the parent table.
They have to share the same
primary key in the beginning,
the same primary key prefix.
And then it is
interleaved and stored
on the same split
as your parent row.
Now, the danger is,
if you have one parent
row and a lot of data which
relates to that parent row,
you basically, again, end
up with all the traffic
to that data to the child
table in one split, which
also leads to hotspotting.
So be careful with that.
It is a technique to speed up
certain queries, especially
if you need to do some kinds of
fast lookups for certain data,
where you want to benefit
from data locality.
You can use interleaving,
but be careful of it.
Same applies to indexes.
So indexes are just
tables in Spanner.
So if you index a
monotonic field,
you get in the same problem.
You get also into hotspotting.
So be careful there.
Use application-level
sharding key prefix,
or something that is
natural in your table
that you can use to
prefix your indexes.
Now, for complex transactions,
one of the things
is Spanner basically
locks on cell level.
So if you have columns and
rows, the lock level for Spanner
is on the cell level.
But if you do, for instance,
a read/write transaction,
where you select on
a non-key column,
then your entire table
for that column is locked.
Because we don't know
what is the range,
how many actually it could be.
We also lock for
new rows inserted,
or for any rows that
are updated, which
could be qualifying
for that filter
that you set on
a non-key column.
So we're basically
locking the entire column.
And with this, you could
run into, basically,
contention for your writes.
So be careful with this.
A good strategy to do
this is, if you can,
use a primary key
in your filter,
so that you basically
can filter down
on the primary key, which
allows that we don't
do a full-column table lock.
And the other thing
is, if you can,
do lookups or filtering
before you do actually
the read/write transaction.
So a good technique is doing
a read-only transaction
before your read/write
transaction,
get the data that you
really want to modify.
Get the primary keys of
that, and then use that,
and verify that the
data hasn't changed
in your read/write transaction.
And then you have a much smaller
scope of your transaction,
and by that, you avoid a
lot of the write contention.
So to that point, use read/write
transactions only if needed.
So read-only transactions
are actually lockless.
So read-only transactions just
use the TrueTime timestamp.
And we don't do any locks.
We don't do a read
lock or anything.
The only time you actually
acquire a read lock
is inside a read/write
transaction, if you do a read.
Otherwise, you don't acquire
any locks in your queries,
or transactions.
Now, another thing that we see,
in terms of read contention,
where you have a lot of data--
hotspotting during
reads-- one of the things
is if you have popular items.
It could be, for
instance, a counter.
For a counter, we recommend
to shard the counter
if you need one.
It could be a popular item.
Let's say you have a social
graph in your Spanner database,
and you have that star that
everybody looks up and wants
to get the latest news.
So to avoid these kinds
of hot data points,
one technique that you can do
is replicating during writes.
So basically, when you
write, you do replicas,
and then you enable the
read from these replicas.
These writes are
transactional, so you don't
get the inconsistency in there.
Or if you can look
at your schema,
if you can do things
like reordering columns
to avoid these hot data spots.
Another thing, indexes.
Consider how you
define your indexes.
Also, the same is
for primary keys.
Spanner always scans from
the top of the table, OK?
So if you have your
index order ascending,
and you ask for that
index for-- let's say,
you have an index on updated
and some app level sharding
to avoid hotspotting.
And you want to have
the latest updates
on certain kinds of data.
And you have your index
defined descending.
The index doesn't help you.
Define your index descending
so that the newest values are
at the top, and you don't
need to scan the entire index.
Another important thing--
since Cloud Spanner
is a distributed database,
we don't have optimizations
that you find in single
machine databases.
So if you look at indexes in
a single machine relational
database, the way that
indexes are implemented--
if they are implemented
performantly--
is that they are actually
pointing directly
to the data point on
your disk, or in memory,
where that data lives.
Now, in Spanner,
that is not possible
because that data could
live on a different node.
The index that you have
might be in a different split
than the data,
actually, that you're
accessing with your query.
So the only thing
that we can do here
is we do actually have to do a
back join to your parent table.
Now, to avoid this, what you
can do in your index definition
is using something
like STORING clause.
So the STORING clause are
columns that are not indexed,
but that you basically attach to
your index that will be carried
around with your index,
and might avoid a back join
into your parent table.
Now, again, the
things that we also
discussed during
the write contention
apply also to read contention.
Consider reordering columns
for better distribution.
Introduce app-level sharding
to basically avoid hotspots.
And then, the other
thing is always
to keep in mind
use indexes wisely.
So indexes are coming with
an improved read performance,
but at the cost of
reduced write because they
are spanning multiple splits.
So pretty much, if you
have an index defined,
unless it's an
interleaved index,
you always will have a two-phase
commit during your writes
because you have
other splits involved
that need to be updated, OK?
So choose them wisely.
Not always the indexes help.
OK?
And they also come at
the storage overhead,
so this is also
something to consider.
Now, if you look at schema
design and life cycles, one
of the things that we see--
especially if you look at
a continuous integration
and delivery setup--
one thing that is done
quite often, actually--
scarily often--
is to do schema changes
with continuous delivery.
And if you deploy
multiple times--
maybe even during
development especially--
if you deploy multiple
times per minute,
for instance, you get all these
schema changes per minute.
And now what happens
is actually--
Spanner is built in a way--
Cloud Spanner is built in
a way to serve live traffic
while schema
changes are ongoing.
So our biggest
primary concern is
we want to serve live
traffic while we also
allow online schema changes.
So we basically take a hit.
We accept the hit on the schema
changes to be propagated.
But for that, you get the
live serving of your traffic.
Now, there's also another thing.
The schema changes
are done sequentially.
There are preparation
phases, which
are done in parallel while
your traffic is going on.
And then, at the point that
we do with the switchover,
we choose a TrueTime timestamp,
they are transactional.
We choose a TrueTime timestamp.
At the point that we
switch over the schema,
we are aborting all
the transactions
that are in flight at that
point that would conflict,
which basically would span
two versions of the schema.
Now, another point
to consider is
we are keeping schema changes
in memory for about an hour,
a little longer.
The reason that we are
doing this is we're
allowing time-bounded reads.
And in time-bounded reads, you
can basically go back in time.
And by going back in
time, you could actually
hit an old schema.
So we still need
to be able to serve
the traffic for that old
schema for time-bounded reads.
So keep that in mind.
It is basically incurring
memory pressure on our nodes
because it's taking up space
if you do a schema change.
And so we are basically lowering
the amount of schema changes
that you can do per time unit.
So really consider
that when you're doing
schema updates, that you
don't do them too often
in a short amount of time.
Also, one thing to
mention is, if you
create indexes, for instance,
in your schema changes,
of course--
as in other databases--
they need to be back-filled,
especially in Spanner
because they are
just normal tables.
We need to back-fill
these indexes.
Depending on the amount
of data that you have,
that can take minutes, hours,
or sometimes even days,
if you have a lot of indexes
that you need to back-fill.
All right.
A couple of things on
the application design.
We introduced recently
the commit timestamps.
So you can now add a
column to your schema
automatically, where you
can say, in your client,
please fill that column
with the commit timestamp.
You can use that, for instance,
if you update any data,
like [INAUDIBLE] this
be automatically filled.
I put it down in Java and Go.
We have that for many, many
other languages, as well.
You see there, you
basically define a constant
that you provide in
your write transaction,
and it will be automatically
filled on the back-end
with the value of the timestamp.
One important thing is also
to benefit from caching,
from query caching.
And to avoid, of course,
SQL injection attacks.
Please use bounded parameters.
These allow you to
basically-- and allow us
to do more efficient caching.
And by that, basically,
lowering also response times
because we don't need to create
a new query plan every time.
All right.
In terms of bulk data imports
and exports, on the one hand,
we have Apache Beam
connector, which
is doing all the hard
work for you to optimize
the export and import of data.
We also have, just recently--
last week, I believe--
announced that we have
import and export built
into Cloud Console.
So what you can do now is
you just click a button.
You say your Google Cloud
Storage destination, and say,
I want to export there.
And then, you can import
from there, as well.
Very long-awaited feature
for many of our customers.
So we're really happy that
this is now available,
and it will actually
improve over time, as well.
Now, if you are
somebody like me,
who wants to actually understand
and do all the bulk loading,
and importing and
exporting yourself,
there is a trick to get
the maximum throughput
for your imports and exports,
especially for the imports,
to avoid the write contention.
I have a video
series around that,
so please feel free
to follow up on that.
But basically, what you do is
you load a large amount of rows
into cache.
You sort these rows
by your primary key.
That can be a composited key.
You're basically
sort it by that.
Then you split them into
chunks, into distinct ranges
of your primary key chunks.
And then you send those
chunks in parallel.
Now, somebody might
say, wait, didn't you
say not monotonic increasing
and decreasing primary key?
Why are you sorting?
The reason here is, you're
sorting and sending in parallel
all these chunks,
which basically means
they go to different splits.
There might be some overlap.
But Spanner will recognize
that, during time,
we do load-balanced
optimizations,
load-balanced splitting,
load-balanced handover
of responsibilities for
splits during your traffic,
so we can actually
optimize that.
And since you send a bunch, or
many, of these sorted ranges
to Spanner, we can actually
get a really high throughput.
So I was able to get
a, I think, 12x speedup
by just using that
technique of importing data.
Another thing which
we recently added
is tracing, which is integrated
directly into Stackdriver.
And I'm going to demonstrate
that in a little bit.
So basically that allows
you to get some insights
into where is your query low?
Is it actually Spanner that
is taking a lot of time?
Is it maybe on your client
side, which uses a lot of time,
and you can actually
optimize on the client side?
So Open Census allows you
to do some tracing there.
And we actually-- if you get
these IDs for your tracers--
they go back into our system.
So we actually can
trace certain queries
that we have found that
are slow on our side.
We can actually use the UID, and
trace them back in our system
and see what was going on.
So that is actually
pretty powerful.
I encourage everybody to
check it out and use it,
and I'm going to show
it in a little bit.
All right.
Let me actually show
that the first time.
So I'm going to switch
over to my demo laptop.
So basically, how
are you setting up
tracing in Cloud Spanner?
I hope it's-- is that visible,
or should I make that a little
bigger?
Let me get that away.
All right.
So basically, to get
Open Census tracing--
this is in Go.
I apologize for anybody
who's not a Go person.
But currently, my
favorite language.
So here in Stackdriver, you
basically define a new exporter
with some Stackdriver options.
In this case, the
project ID and some
attributes that you define.
I basically attached some
labels to my tracers.
I want to have the
demo that is running,
and the region where this
is running in this line.
And then, I set up some views
and register that exporter.
So that basically is
all the setup here.
Last but not least, we apply
a config for this trace
and say, OK, how
many traces do I want
to get from all my requests?
So you see here, I want to have
1% of my requests as traced,
and then these are
sent to Stackdriver.
Now, how does it look
if I do my actual query?
So in my actual query,
let's say I'm doing
a write for a sequential row.
So I do a sequential write here.
So I define a span by
starting that span.
That's just basically
the containment
of my trace for round-trip--
let's say it's that way.
I'm ending that span when
the function is left.
And then I'm using
that context that I'm
using here, and passing that
context down in my library.
So this is really
important if you
use Go, that you
use the same context
and just wrap the context if
you need some other qualities.
So here, for instance, I'm
doing a context with a timeout,
where I say, if, after five
seconds, it doesn't come back,
please cancel that whole thing.
So I'm wrapping the context
that I'm getting in my function
into this timeout context.
And then, at the end,
that's pretty much it.
I don't have to
do anything else.
All the Open Census,
tracing, is already
supported in the library.
It's literally these two rows up
here which enable the tracing.
Now, how does that look
in my [? Explorer? ?]
So we can see
here, for instance,
all the traces that
I've collected.
Let's update this and see
if this is still running.
So we see, OK, this
is still running.
It shows you what are the
times here for these traces.
Now you see that
there are pretty much
three lines in response time.
And the reason for this is,
actually, the most upper line
is clients running in Asia
against a Cloud Spanner
instance in the US.
The middle line is
my clients running
in Europe against my Cloud
Spanner instance in the US.
And the lowest one here, which
has very low round-trip times,
is my clients running in the US
in the same region as my Cloud
Spanner instance.
Now, the great thing
that you can do here
is you can pick one of
those, and show events.
And it shows you, OK, I'm
acquiring a read-only session.
I acquired a read-only
session, and then I'm
going to Spanner
and do the commit.
And you see the 200
milliseconds here.
Now, let's see if I can
maybe find something else.
So here you see,
for instance, we
are iterating-- we're
doing a sequential write.
You see the things
that are going on.
If I'm going a little
bit further down,
let's see if I can find one.
Yesterday, I found
a really nice one
which showed me
that, for instance,
if your session
pool is too small,
and it needs to
require a session,
then you see it's like, OK,
I'm waiting for a session,
I'm waiting for a session.
Oh, now I got a server session.
So the entire query took,
let's say, 500 milliseconds.
But the actual Spanner part
of it was five milliseconds.
The 495 milliseconds
was the client
trying to acquire a session.
And you can fix these
things on your client side.
So you basically get insights
into where is the problem?
Are my queries slow, or
is actually my client
not optimized for the things
that I'm doing with it?
All right.
So the next thing that
I want to talk about
is multi-region configurations.
So we have two offers right now.
We have a multi-region
continental,
and we have a
multi-region global.
Both of them give
you a five nines SLA
So the regional instance
gives you a four nine SLA.
The multi-region gives
you a five nine SLA.
Now, what is continental
multi-region instance?
You get a full copy of a
database in two regions.
You have the Paxos that
I explained earlier
across three regions.
I'm going to go a little bit
in more detail in a second.
And it is available even
if one of your regions,
or read/write regions,
becomes unavailable.
So the same applies for
the multi-region global.
Whereas, for the
multi-region global,
you add two read-only copies
of your full read-only copies
on two more continents.
In this case, Europe and Asia.
Now, how does it look?
For multi-region
continental, you basically
have a region one,
you have a region two,
and then you have a
so-called witness region.
Now, the witness region
has a lock store,
but it doesn't have
a copy of your data.
And the witness region is
basically somebody who has
voting rights, but
cannot serve data.
Now, why do we need
this witness region?
We need it, actually, for
the high availability.
Now, let's assume your region
two becomes unavailable, right?
If you only would have these
two regions in your quorum--
you cannot really get a quorum.
So you could have a split brain.
You don't want that.
So you need some
kind of third region
to get the majority in your
votings for the Paxos group.
And the witness region
has this function for you.
So now, if region two,
for instance, goes down,
we can still serve
data from region one
because the witness region
helps to have the quorum
for the transactions.
Now, on a global
setup, you basically
have region one read/write.
You have another
region read/write--
in the US, in this case.
Now, for quorums, again, you
also have a witness region.
Depending how far they
are away from each other,
you incur their round-trip
times for your transactions,
especially in the
two-phase commit.
And then you have the
read-only regions,
which are on the write
side, in Europe and in Asia.
Now, what do you read-only
regions bring you?
First, they are
there to serve data.
So not always you
have to ship data
from your read/write regions.
Second, if you use stale,
time-bounded consistent reads,
these can be served directly
from your read-only regions
if we have the
latest data there.
So if you use 10 seconds, you're
pretty much safe to use that.
So in the case of writes
and consistent reads,
you see the blue lines on
the right is a strong read.
Now if we get basically
in from-- a client in Asia
goes into the read-only
copy in Asia and asks,
hey, I want to
have the data, what
we incur is this round-trip
time to read/write region.
And ask, hey, do we
have the latest data?
Then we get the response, and
we serve the data from Asia.
Now, if you have
a write, we don't
go to the read-only region.
We go directly to the
read/write region,
where the splits live in
the read/write regions.
Now, if a US line comes in,
it's pretty much the same
as you have for regional.
Now, if you have
time-bounded ones,
again, you basically go
to your read-only region.
If it is within the bounds that
you have that data already,
you can serve it
without even consulting
your read/write region.
OK.
So before I go in
the related session,
I just want to show, my
last couple of minutes,
a couple of things.
So one that I want to do
is I want to start a demo.
So what I built here--
I just want to explain
it a little bit.
So if you go to the
showcase in Moscone West,
and you go to the
Cloud Spanner showcase,
we have one that illustrates the
manageability of Cloud Spanner.
And then, there's
station two, where
you can play with scaling the
number of nodes out and in,
and scaling the
throughput up and down.
And it shows you how
quickly Spanner actually
adapts to changing
throughputs, as well as
how quickly nodes that you
add become available to serve
your workload.
It's pretty amazing.
So I've built this
app, or the back-end,
by having clients
running in Kubernetes.
And they are attaching
to a Pub/Sub session.
And then I can use
Pub/Sub to send a message
and instruct them how
much traffic to serve,
how much traffic to send
against Cloud Spanner--
so how much read
traffic, how much
write traffic, how much
time-bounded read traffic.
Now, I find that very powerful
because it is a very easy way
to have an interface to
communicate with, especially,
the agency that built the
station and the back-end
that I was building.
So in this case,
what I want to show
is I set up a system
where I want to show you
the differences between a
multi-regional continental
and a multi-regional
global instance,
in terms of what the latencies
are that you're going to see.
So let's have a look here.
I'm going to change to, let's
say, multi-region global.
Now I'm going to
save these changes.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT KUBIS: Oh.
Thank you very much.
I apologize for that.
OK.
So basically what you see
here, in the upper graph, is--
it's showing on this all right.
So the yellow line is the
random reads coming from the US.
No, the yellow is Asia--
random reads from Asia.
The blue ones, or the second
line from the top, is Europe,
and the lowest one is US.
So you can see the US random
reads for a global instance is
nine milliseconds.
These are point reads.
And for Asia, it's 165.
And for Europe, it's 114.
So these are strong reads, OK?
Now, if we look at time-bounded
ones, we see here, all of them
are below 10 milliseconds.
So this is the power
of time-bounded reads.
These time-bounded reads
have a staleness up to 10
milliseconds--
10 seconds, apologies.
They have staleness
up to 10 seconds.
But all of them are served
within 10 milliseconds.
So that is the power.
Especially if you want
to filter your data,
you can use it very nicely.
Now, if we look at the
multi-region continental,
what you see there is pretty
much very similar times.
But now, as you can
see, the random reads
are 185 milliseconds.
So we had, before,
like 140 milliseconds.
So the reason for
that is the data
has always to be
shipped to my clients
in Asia because they don't
have a read-only copy.
So even for these
point reads, it
makes a 40-millisecond,
roughly, difference
by having this read-only copy
in Asia, in the local region.
Now, I want to show one more
thing, if it is working.
Let's see.
Yep.
So here, I am displaying,
again, random writes.
So we have here, writes from
the US-- about 30 milliseconds.
This is going to a
regional instance.
From Asia, around 200
milliseconds, and from Europe,
about 130 milliseconds
round-trip time.
The sequential writes,
right now, it has started.
It's about the same.
Now, if I would put that up--
it takes a little bit of time--
you basically would see
that Spanner tops out
at 35% of usage
in your instance,
because I'm basically
always hitting the last bit.
So the throughput that I would
get for the sequential writes
is much lower, even though
I have the same amount
of compute resources available.
All right.
So last but not least,
related sessions.
There is a session
right now, which
you have missed, so
thank you for coming here
instead of that session--
[LAUGHTER]
--which is about replacing
Oracle with Cloud Spanner.
You can watch it on YouTube.
We will be recording
all these sessions
and putting them up on YouTube.
So you might not have
missed it completely,
because you can go back
and watch it at 2x.
Tomorrow is a session about
migrating Cloud Spanner, which
is talking about migrating
from NetScaler database.
In that case, I
think, my [INAUDIBLE]
that they are talking about.
We have also another
session this afternoon,
where Bandai Namco, a
Japanese games company,
built from the ground up
on Cloud Spanner, a game.
Really interesting.
I worked with them last
year at Next Tokyo.
I really recommend going there.
And then, tomorrow's
also, like, what's
new about Cloud Spanner
from the PM, Deepti, who is
talking about roadmap features.
And last but not least, a little
bit advertising about myself.
Please, if you are interested
in ongoing topics around Cloud
Spanner, I have a video series
on YouTube, which is called
"TIL about Cloud Spanner."
So you see that here, which
basically means things
I learned about Cloud
Spanner, or today I
learned about Cloud Spanner.
You pick your favorite.
You can scan the QR code.
You can also follow me on
Twitter, under @hostirosti.
I'm mostly tweeting
about technology,
very rarely about
personal things.
And with that, thank
you very much for--
[APPLAUSE]
--attending my talk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]